我们做的最后的一些准备
比如说很多小伙伴已经完成了我们课程的作业
将近有100多个同学教了我们的作业
然后呢
有40多个同学达到了我们的毕业的标准
还有十几个同学是全部答对
非常的厉害
然后呢
我们课程组就很用心地设计了一个
我们的毕业证书
那我们也极尽所能
我们想让我们的证书看上去更漂亮和专业一点
那么也就是说所有的这些小伙伴的话
你们把你们的地址在群里面告诉我们的
课程的助理
我们会把这些那个证件证书发给你
我相信的话
也会帮助同学们未来在寻找自己的工作呀
在自己的求那个求职啊
那个求学的道路上
也是大家的一个certificate
因为就是games104的课程
这些作业全部做完的话
实际上本身还是蛮挑战的
就是说昨天的话恭喜我们这些同学们
然后另外一件事情的话呢
也就是说啊实际上随着课程的逐渐的接近尾声
那我们就课程组的话
终于有些时间
就是把前面这将近十几个十个月吧
没有有没有十个月哦
将近有六个多月我们做的这些课程
然后呢把这些资料准备好
所以我们会把我们的课程整理成文字版
这样方便同学们去阅读
同时的话呢
大家可以关注我们课程的这样的一个公众号
这样在这里面的话呢
我们会持续性的把那个PICO小引擎持续更新
因为那个也是我们的爱
然后前面一直在准备课程
大家都非常的忙
确实准备课程压力太大了
但现在随着课程那个准备
我们可以告一段落的时候
那我们可以有更多的时间
好好的跟大家一起维护我们的piccolo引擎
包括一直欠大家的
我们的PICO的源码解读啊
包括我带着大家一起去给我们的皮卡罗
增加一些更多的feature对吧
说不定一年后会有很多同学用皮卡做出自己的
很酷的大作业
很酷的这个毕设很酷的游戏
那作业这一点的话
非常的兴奋
那么最后呢其实课程组终于有时间做一些
这个就是说呃怎么说呢
回顾和总结的事情
那这里面的话呢
其实啊哇这里面有个tb
实际上我们课程组的话
前两天把我们POO引擎里面所有的知识点
全部做了个图谱
大家看到这个图谱上是不是密密麻麻
对不对
不好意思啊
那只是整个图谱的1/10都不到
其实它是一张很巨大很巨大的图
到时候我们课程组会把这个图分享给大家
然后确实准备这个课程的话
我们花了好多好多的时间啊
就是查了上万种材料啊
然后总结了大概1500多个知识点以上
然后呢
其实将近2000多个人天wow在这个那个工作里面
所以的话呢希望同学们会喜欢我这门课
那么在今天的课程结束的时候
大家不要走
我们会有一个课程组精心准备的一个彩蛋视频
也是送给我们所有能坚持到最后一刻的小伙伴
然后呢
也就是也是表达一下
我们课程组这一这将近半年以来我们的情感
我们特别想和大家一起say个hi
这也是第一次我们课程组让全员让大家看到
OK所以呢感谢的话先说先先说这些
我们还要回到我们今年课程的正文
那上一节课呢因为准备的特别仓促
所以欠了大家的QNA对吧
那这节课我们先补上大家的QNA
那么第一个问题的话
大家就问我们说诶
这个在ECS这个架构里面的话
如何解解决一个NT被删掉这件事情
其实在ECS架构里面呢
它追求的这个就是硬件的性能
所以说它它一般一个ANTITY或者被删掉的时候呢
他不会真的把内存释放掉
因为大家知道
每一次内内存的allocate和DEALLOCATE的话
都会牵扯到那个hip的这种操作就会很慢
所以呢它其实只是把那个index把它制成空了
那下次再有一个新的allocation的话
那直接reduce那个index
那么怎么样的区别
就是新版的那个音ITY和老板的entity呢
我们在之前跟大家讲过
就是加一个salt对吧
SD一般就是累加的
就是意味着就是说
所以我每个东西看到的时候啊
诶我看到你的index是一样的
但我的salt吃的不一样
我就知道哦
这个之前指向那个nt handle是无效的
所以简单来讲的话
在这种高效的这种非常高频的这种啊
这个系统里面的话
我们会尽可能降低memory allocation的第一个allocation
我们把内存直接有一个有一个链表
直接把所有free space全部串在这
然后直接就用起来了
那么第二第二个同学问我们说
哎我们怎么去测量这个catch beast
哎呀这个问题就非常的难了
首先第一个呢啊在程序里面
我们自己去测KASHMISS其实是很难的一件事
但是我们可以估算对吧
但是的话呢实际上一般都要基于GPU厂商提供的
这样的一些工具
把我们的application跑起来
挂上那个挂到那个那个那个那个就是工具里面
然后呢他会帮我们抓到说诶你的CPU cg啊
你的这个l to l three cash的这个miss啊对吧
会告诉我
那比如说在英特尔的CPU上
我们有个工具叫wow tube
他会告诉你这样的东西
所以小伙伴们如果想写这种高性能的代码的话
一定要学会用这些工具
包括我们教rendering里面很多讲到的cash
miss这些东西的话
其实在GPU上也有这样的一些就PROFING的工具
这一般都是硬件厂商给你开放出来的
因为你自己是没有办法知道那个硬件的spec
对吧
那最底层的那些接口函数
那么第三个问题呢
就是说诶就是说我们如何给designer
一个面向数据编程的
这样的一个架构的工具集啊
这个要求实在是太高了
因为其实当我们在一个真实的游戏团队
你们工作的时候
你会发现就是说在游戏团队里面
我们的艺术家artist
我们的设计师
designer和programmer程序员是完全三种不同的物种
真的大家的这个这个这个思维方式
差别是非常非常大的
这其实也是这个就是说我觉得做游戏也好
游戏引擎一个乐趣
就是说因为你实际上游戏引擎的本质是什么呢
我们是做工具的对吧
我给大家一直在讲
就是我们是做工具的
那么你的工具的使用对象
他的思维方式和做工具的人是完全不一样的
对吧
artist看见一个东西
他就喜欢边边边往上往上去那个贴对吧
他就是他不会去特别在意这个结构和逻辑
而designer呢更多的是希望AI will express myself
就是说我希望表达我自己对吧
我希望创造出各种各样
如果你告诉我说一辆车必须有这五个部件构成
那我一定要做一辆车
是用加上一些额外的功能
跟你想象的那个车完全不一样
为什么
因为这样的车才会有耗
才会有这个我们叫NOVT
就是说比较有趣
比较有创意
对不对
所以designer天然的就是要打破你设计的这个
Paradise
就你设计的范式
所以呢在DP里面的话呢
我们是希望每一个component它的那个模组啊
就是这个功能都是明确的单一的
这和designer的需求是天然是有冲突的
但是呢怎么说呢
其实在我们在做这样的一个一个架构的时候
给自己的工具
我们尽量的把每个component变成一个个的积木
然后呢哎让designer自己去组合
但是相信我
designer可能很快就会需要一些不一样的东西
那这里面的话呢其实我们需要做一个工具
告诉第三点说
诶如果你希望做一个非常customize的功能的话
那么你就可能不能走那个DOP的pipeline
它的性能可能只有DOP的110
你愿不愿意
比如说我给他一个budget
他就是说总的性能的bug
然后他就他就开始思考了
说嗯
我是以十倍的成本做一个非常酷的一辆车呢
还是以非常高效的这个成本
我做100辆车对吧
这就是让他去想的一个问题了
那么所以呢工具测的话呃
首先他一定要允许这个设计师去组合
另外一个的话呢就是说呃我们不去替他做选择
但是呢我们要非常清晰的把他做的每一个选择
所产生的这个成本告诉他
所以呢其实在真正的实战性的游戏团队里面
就巴基control就是预算的控制
包括呢这个预算的这个visualization
就是说这个预算指的不是钱啊
这你们讲的哎我的CPU的性能啊
GPU的性能
我这个预算控制
包括直接可视化
其实是非常重要的一件事情
如果讲的更深一点的话
包括我们的QA流程
也就是说你做了设计师做了一版的改动
然后呢整个游戏不就变了吗
那游戏里面有那么多的关卡
我跑一遍
我要保证它的性能完全符合我的需求
那这件事情的话呢其实也是非常复杂的
而且在真正的实战性游戏团队里面的话
这些流程全部都是自动化的
也就是说设计师改了一个玩法
那或者改了一个比如说小怪的AI啊
或者兵团这个这个这个
或者说NPC作战的模型啊
那其实很多的测试全部会自动发生
告诉我们说对性能有没有大的变化对吧
包括他自己也要知道收到这个report
那么第四个问题呢
就是说哎这是跟我们上一节有关的
就跟我们说诶the moon
你们能不能就是如何解处理这个自发光的材质
对吧
其实我记得我在那一刻我特别强调了这件事情
就是说其实四方光材质呢
它的lighting
在这个就是说在传统的我们的rendering里面的话
其实是比较难以处理的
我们很多时候会给它加一个fake lighting
加一个假的光源
挂在那个自发光的材质上
看起来就像你身上有个led照亮了
但是在lumen的这个结构里面的环境
其实对于这种低频的自发光
它解决的还真的是蛮不错的
就是大家大家如果急得我上一节课讲的
就是说这个四方框材质呢
它这个radiance会写到一个单独的surface cash里面
那里面有个emission的那个channel的那个texture
然后呢
当我们在空间中采样了一个个的
就是water metric lighting的时候
这些光这些radio全部会被踩进去的
踩进去之后呢
当我再去生成那个screen space的那个probe的时候
这些光就会被踩到我的这个screen space里面去
而且呢它还有很神奇的设定
大家记得吗
就是左脚踩右脚踢云纵对吧
我这一帧的光到下一站又变成我的intro lighting
这样的话我的那个就是自发光的multi bounce
实际上也可以在这个就是说一帧一帧
一帧的去这个传递中的话
形成multi bounce的这样的一个效果
所以说我个人觉得lumen里面在解决自发光的
这个就是特别是自发光的这个这个就是GI
也就自发光形成在场景里多次反射的效果的话
这个方法其实还蛮漂亮的
但是呢我自己也很希望能够做一些实验
看看它最终的效果怎么样
比如说这个自发光我能不能支持HDR呀对吧
它的效果是不是足够明显和准确啊
这个需要花一点时间我们再去验证一下
但是整体的它的结构做得还是蛮好的好
OK那这就是我们今天的QN的内容
也算是回那个还了我们上一节课挖的一个坑好
那今天就到我们的课程的主题了对吧
NAT耶
这个哇
这个简直是一个神坑级的这样的一个topic
那么NT的话呢
实际上也是大家很关注的
这一代游戏引擎的一个很很顶级的一个技术
那么我们也是花了很长一段时间去理解
NT这个技术去分析
也希望给小伙伴讲的清楚
但实际上这个准备课的过程是实话实说
是非常艰辛的
我我我们课程组的小伙伴经常会争得面红耳赤
我记得我在课程备课中最常讲的一句话说
哎你们不要忽悠我对吧
因为其实呃从它的本身的PPT啊
到作者的讲解啊
其实这里面空白的地方盲区还是很多的
所以呢我们课程组最后大家真的很多时候
被迫打开源代码
一行一行源代码去看
包括也做了很多小实验
确保我们对它的理解尽可能的去正确
那么基于类似于上一节课的我们的传统
就是说我们不太会把原始的这个这个presentation
顺序的给大家讲一遍
因为原作者讲的肯定比我们好
我们尝试给予我们的理解
从这个技术的源头讲到这个技术里面
最关键的我们认为的一个大的结构点
有些细节我们会跳过
但是呢我们要确保
把最核心的东西给大家点出来
好啊
废话不多说
到我们今天的正题
NT对吧
一个新一代的这个geometry pipeline
就是无限极和细节的叫pipeline
那么首先的话呢在理解NANA的这个事情的话
哎我们要去开始复古的理解一下
就是我们在前面那么多节课讲的
rendering pipeline对吧
其实我们在前面讲的很多rendering pipeline
实际上呢是一个传统的render
那么这个pine一个很大的特点是什么呢
就是所有的需求是在CPU那一端发起的
就是我们经常会发生一个桌扩
那么大家如果学open g2
那学direct
你们会知道一个指令叫draw primitive对吧
画一画一个mesh
告诉他vertex啊
index啊对吧
一小篇match出来这个东西呢
其实啊在GPU上
首先呢你还要准备一大堆的
这个你要用哪个texture呀
你的阿尔法布兰妮设成什么样子呀
你一大堆的我们叫做render state
这一大堆都设计好之后诶
你进入那个漫长的pipeline
在CPU里面他还要通过swapping到GPU里面
然后GPU里面开始进行这个处理来跑vs p s
还有rust riser
那其实在这个过程中啊
很多时候CPU实际上是第一个
它速度可能跟不上GPU
第二件事情呢
CPU本身会有大量的算力
会浪费在准备这些素材的本身
大家可能都不知道
就是说桌括其实是一个非常expensive的东西
比如说我们以前大家还记得我们在讲SHADER
讲材质的时候
尽量讲材质
同一个材质的渲染
我们要merge在一起
为什么呢
因为我们这样可以把他的桌这个设置
那个render set全部merge在一起
其实这一条长长的排不来
就是哪怕你就画一个一个三角形的话
整个pi你得走一遍
所以这是垂直上的render一个很头疼的问题
那么这样的一个问题之后呢
其实啊对于现代游戏来讲
现代游戏的特点是什么
就是哇我的几何会
这个就是我们的场景中的这个几何
会非常的复杂对吧
而且有很丰富的材质
大家还记得我上次给大家讲那个就是啊
在那个迪斯尼那个那个那个报告中
他讲
他说他一个屏幕上好像是有上千上千种材质吧
对吧
那这里的组合就会爆炸了
我有我有我的mesh
哪个mesh呢
我渲染的时候我有我的render state对吧
我mesh还有我的LOD怎么设置
然后呢我还要设置我的材质
材质可不是一个参数
它有一大堆的参数
还包括各种各样的texture对吧
然后呢我还有skinny with animation哇
这就是一个combination
就是什么组合爆炸了
对不对
那这个时候当我们去做客的时候
我们每一个组合我得扩一次桌括
你想我们要扣多少次桌扩
而且呢为了每次周末之前
我还要propel它的render state
大家如果对现代GPU
包括在显卡的
这个是那个性能有所一些了解的话
大家都知道就是这个render state的这个这个设置啊
其实本身是非常expensive的
非常贵的
所以的话这就会导致就是说诶按照传统PIPINE
如果绘制像现代
特别是3A级游戏这样复杂的场景的话
它基本上是跑不动的对吧
它就是会非常非常的费
但是呢好消息是什么呢
就是说在这样的一个这样的一个情况下呢
我们就会发现
就是说GCPU实际上会被做了大量的
比如说计算
比如说我们做的wow russian colin对吧
就是这个在CPU里算完
对不对
然后C哥算完结果我还得提交给GPU
而且GPU呢这个时候很多说他啥也干不了
他只能等着CPU把这数据准备好
而且呢就是说在java里面
每一次去change exchange的render state的话
本身也会非常的费
所以呢这是traditional rendering pipeline
就是非常头疼的一件事
这也是就是已经成为了一个瓶颈
那这个瓶颈呢实际上他的曙光是在哪里呢
就是第一个就是随着这个2010十年前
computer shader逐渐逐渐的成熟
到现在为止
computer shader已经非常成熟了
那么他呢就可以做一件事情
什么意思
就是我们可以不用在CPU和GPU之间来回导数据
大家还记得我们在之前讲过
就是我从一个数据从CPU里考进GPU对吧
这个事情是很废的
因为在CPU里面的话呢
我的这些render pipi
还得从这个memory里面load到cash
Cash
再到我的pick shader workshop去处理
那能不能所有的计算就在GPU的内部
那就有个前提
比如说我要做一个唉世间锥裁剪
这里面一大堆的数学运算
对不对
那能不能在GPU里面写一个通用的计算器
把它处理掉
它的曙光是什么呢
就是计算SHADER
Computer shader
那么它呢就是说可以完全的在GPU上做出大量的
以前只能在CPU上做的通用计算
所以呢就是说这样就使得我们的很多的这个
CPU和GPU之间的通讯变得非常的简单
那么另外一个的话呢就是rendering API
以前的话呢
我们一个桌primitive只能画一个mesh
对不对
哎但是现在我们可以做indirect的时候
我们可以把一个就是这个array of the parameters
或者叫一个parameter buffer
把它整个录得进去
我一个周末可以画很多的mesh
那这样的话也是使得我们能够尽量的减少
就是在CPU到GPU的桌括这件事情上
就是成为了可能
所以的话呢其实在就是56年前
其实更早一点
就是说大家应该是我67年前了
更早了
就是说大家提出来了
就是说哎我们以前是一个一个对象的渲染
我能不能把以前很多CPU的给rendering做的计算
比如像visibility啊
l o d selection啊对吧
全部把它移到这个GPU上去
而且呢我把整个场景数据全部放到显存
大家看打开现在的显卡
你们发现一个特点
没有显存都很大对吧
动辄就是几个G的
所以我整个场景其实是可以基本放进去的
对不对
那我就不想让这个CPU再去做什么操作
CPU只是发一条指令
说把场景给我绘制一遍
我设置一下相机参数对吧
剩下的事情最好你GPU全部搞定诶
那这样的话
这个我们就从以前的一个draw primitive
就变成了一个JC
这个呢其实就是我们讲的时候哎
现代GPU上GPU driven的rendering pipeline
最理想的最终极的状态
那么这样的一个很大的好处是什么呢
就大家还记得
我以前在一开始给大家讲的
就是游戏引擎的架构里面
游戏引擎它是一个对实时性要求非常高的一个
一个一个就是SDK
那么大家想想游戏里面除了渲染啊
是不是还有很多其他的东西啊
比如说我们的这个AI对吧
我们的游戏逻辑对吧
我们的各种各样的玩法
把物理检测一大堆东西
对不对
那这些东西的话呢
我们啊包括网络通讯
那我们就可以把这些东西
全部放回到这个CPU来做
这CPU一下子就被释放出来了
那么GPU呢就等于说渲染的东西交给显卡
你来做了对吧
我CPU就不要在这瞎忙活了
以前大家如果看的话
render thread是很满的
对不对
后来为了解决这个问题的话
我们还提供了就是这个多线程的这个state的提交
这个大家如果了解一下DX12的话
这个架构包括我很架构是很核心的
就是个多性能的提交
那么哎但是的话呢
其实这个时候我CPU资源大量的被浪费
所以这些东西啊
其实是我们讲的这个就是后面要讲的cost
Brendering
visb buffer啊
包括我们讲的NAT的话
它最原始的一个思想
就是说我希望整个这个世界的几何的裁剪
LOD的选择
甚至包括几何的这个就是选择哪些东西
可见不可见
全部在CPU内部完成
然后呢我尽量不要让CPU特别的慢
所以这个是我们这节课的体验
就是什么时候我们能从一个draw
primitive到JC
这是我们要解决的问题
这里面最早的这个先先驱者呢
就是我自己找到的是那个刺客信条
大革命那一作
对
这里面应该叫secret
这个这个这个那个unu unity对吧
那么其实呢就是GPU driven的这个pipeline的话
最早是他在我印象中是2015年SEGA上
他们给了一个分享
这个确实做的非常的了不起
他们要解决什么一个问题
就是大家看大革命这一组啊
他所展现的那个场景
有大量的这个精细的
这个这个这个巴黎的这种建筑啊
那些浮雕其实非常的让人震撼对吧
那么这么里面这么多的精细的几何
你去怎么去渲染它
怎么去绘制它
其实是个非常难的一个问题
在过去传统里面我们去表达这个几何的话
没有办法
我只能把整个几何low的进去对吧
然后呢我就开始一个instance
一个inst的rendering
但是呢这里面就会出现很多问题
就比如说很多的instance其实是不可见的
甚至是对于一个建筑来讲
一个建筑是对不对
但是你看到他的前面的柱子
它柱子后面的很多
虽然也属于这个建筑的mesh
它其实也是不可见的对吧
那我要为这些东西设置多少个状态
那么我才能解决我的这个渲染高效率的问题呢
就是大家想象一下
如果我有上亿级的这个面片的话
我去渲染它的时候
实际上我里面可能有上万个物体
我怎么去渲染它
其实这就是当时大革命这一作的话
它所面临的一个非常大的挑战
那他怎么解决呢
诶他们是最早提出来说
我们用cluster based rendering方法去解决它
这个方法呢讲起来很高大上
实际上是非常简单的一个淳朴的思想
就是说对于一个每一个这个游戏世界里面的
一个instant的一个物体对吧
它可能是几万个面甚至十几个方面很大
但是呢我把它分成无数个
有128个三角形呃
应该是他选择当时选的是64个三角形对吧
这不重要
大概就是一个小的固定尺寸的一个叫cluster
这样的一个一个一个一小片的mesh
那这样的话呢
其实我就可以把一个instance
分成无数个小的cluster
而每一个小小的caster呢
它实际上都可以做自己的BINBOX
那这样就好了呀
当我去去渲染这个东西的时候
我以前只是检测说这个instance是不是可见对吧
但是现在我有了这cluster的时候
其实我可以检测什么呢
每个class是不是可见
而且呢每个cluster他的是不是会被背面裁剪
会不会被那个depth去遮挡掉
这样的话
我对整个这个世界的表达的颗粒度就会细
非常非常多
哎这个东西听上去有点反直觉啊
但是其实这个是非常重要的一个observation
就是说因为我们在computer shader里面的话
我们是可以就是批量的处理
这种uniform的结合的
但是的话呢我们整体的去对于每个instance
LOD切换啊
包括就是这个我的卡林对吧
我大家知道我们画一个instance
无论这个东西可不可见
但是你如果有10万个三角形
只要这个instance
我只要一个角可见的话
那10万3角形我得整个再炫一遍
这个其实是很废很废的
但是你想一下
如果我们在大革命这样的一个场景里面的话
很多时候这些建筑这些东西
它本身就是一个很精细的模型
但是你站在一个里面的话
你看到的就是它一小块
所以呢哎我把这些mash分成很多cluster的话
实际上理论上来讲
它可以实现对船购的这个最大化的利用
就是对于所有不可能看见的三角形
我是尽可能少地绘制它对吧
所以这个看上去很复杂
但其实大家如果仔细推演一下
你会发现他对几何的利用率是最高的
那么他这个拍拍案想起来呢其实也非常的简单
这是他画的整个这个流程图
它首先在蓝色的
在CPU的部分呢
它其实就是对这个instant做了一个最简单的
比如说view russian coming对吧
然后呢在GPU阶段的话
它会进行一个比较精细的这个view fcm
它就是会把很多的看不见的instance给卡掉
这里面其实还包括depth
然后呢每个instance的话
就是每一个物体它又会分成很多的cluster对吧
他把这个cluster再做斯卡林
这样我把这个可见的这个物体的
不可见的那些小的部分全部也扔掉
然后呢我把这些锁
然后呢每个cluster它不是164个面嘛
对不对
我甚至把一些不可见的三角形我都扔掉
最后呢我把所有的可见的啊
这个讲起来比较拗口了
叫可见的instance的可见的clustered
可见的船go
把他们全部packing成一个超大的index buffer
它这个过程叫什么呢
叫index buffer
compact compaction对吧
然后哎我最后一个桌扩或者一个indirect jk
可以是这个这个这个INTELJA
也可能MULTINTELJAL诶
我就把你整个场景画出来了对吧
这其实就是当时刺客信条他这一做的时候
它的一个核心的思想
你可以理解成
就是说他在前面用这么多的GPU的运算
包括这么复杂的class base的结构
诶他做了一件事是什么呢
就是啊做了一个超级的这个啊visibility carly
就是把所有不可见的triangle
尽可能给你全部干掉了
而且呢把所有可见的这些几何
全部group成了一个大把粉
然后呢我一个周后我把你全部搞定
所以它就达到了性能的最优
同时的话呢也尽可能降低了屏幕上呢
我们叫做什么呢
叫这个这个这个overdraw
就是说同一个pixel我很多三角形画的话
他们就彼此之间产生了浪费嘛
这个其实是它最核心的思想
那么这个思想为什么我要先讲它呢
因为其实大家去理解NT的话
他的思想的源头实际上是来自于这个思路
就是clasps rendering
那么包括就是我们看到那个非常有意思
就是啊
发明这个就是COSPARENDERING的这个这些老歌的话
那会写很多的
这个twitter就是在讨论说诶
你NT哪些技术是你更厉害的
哪些技术是我发明的对吧
彼此之间还在讨论说谁才是这个技术的发明者
但是没关系
我们不卷入他们的争论
但是呢确实这个就是大革命的这一作的话
确实引发了一个class based
rendering的这样的一个革命
那么其实在GPU赛呢
CPU赛就是在那个就是非常的简单的
他只是做了一个非常简单的
就是对instant cotree的一个coming in对吧
他就是把这个就是说那些各种各样的桌括呢
他还做了一件事
就是说根据你的材质不同
他做了一个哈希表
把你相同的材质
相同的render state的东西
尽可能顾不到一起往里面去去去去提交
那么接下来的话呢我就把每一个instant data
无论是你的transform l o d啊
你应该用哪一层的LOD啊
注意啊
这里面在大革命里面的话
每个instance l o d是自己算的
就是这个其实还有一个古典做法
就是说啊比如说这边有个柱子
它讲的是一个是一个instance的话呢
它的LOD是整体说我切的LOD0
还是12345depends
我靠近相机的距离
这个其实后面我会讲了
这其实是和那个NT有个本质的不同呢
我们先不讲开
那这些信息呢诶我把它packing成一个buffer
然后一股脑就交给我们的GPU来开始处理了
那GPU干什么事情呢
其实GPU非常的简单
哎这个虽然这个图画看上去非常的复杂
但是我尝试用最简单的方法去解给大家讲清楚
就是说呢
哎我这个时候我就有一个
我现在要绘制的instance的列表
对不对
那么我一个每个instance的假设
大家知道有几万个三角形
对不对
我呢把这个几万个三角形分成很多的cluster
但是呢很多的cluster呢其实太碎了
他还做了一个叫chunk对吧
就chunk
就是你可以认为就是把一群cluster grp到一起
比如说啊16个啊
或者32个对吧
这个depends on他的选择可能一般是32个
为什么呢
就是这个里面有个小的trick
就是说我们在这个就是说显卡里面
我们的那个那个
就是大家还记得我们的每一个computer shader对吧
他有一个叫wave或者叫wave from
或者叫那个那个叫安安VIDIA
叫WP
就是说我一次次性发出一批工作对吧
把我所有的working thread全部吃满
一般来讲的话NVIDIA是32个工作同时发
然后呢那个AMD的话以前是64个对吧
但是呢其实就是说
你如果能够把所有的thread全部用完的话
效率最高
所以这个CHK的意思也就是说哎我一个cluster
一个我这一批就扔出去了
所以呢他其实在这个cluster和这个那个instance
之间又建了一层唱K的架构
但是大家不用特别担心这个东西
这个东西其实只是个加速架构
对吧好
那我的这个有这个唱歌的时候
当然这里面多说一句
就是在后面我们讲nut的时候
有个东西特别难理解
叫cluster group
就是我们把cluster变成一个group
其实跟这个呢有那么一丢丢的异曲同工之妙
包括我后面会讲的就是说那个class group的话
使得大家去理解NT产生了非常多的困难
我们尝试今天把这件事情讲清楚
OK那么其实呢每个instance的话呢
它中间分成一个个chunk
每个CHK里面包含了若干个cluster
没关系
我先去看唱歌的可见性好
接下来我去干什么呢
诶我看每一个cluster的可见性
那cluster的可见性
每个class有自己的绑定嘛对吧
包括我可以做自己的这个那个depth testing
我什么都可以做
诶这个时候呢我还能做什么事情呢
就是在cluster呢
它实际上是一个曲面
对不对
但有些三角形呢是在我的正面
有的三角形是在我的背面
对吧
我还可以把背面的三角形给干掉
那么我能进一步降低我的三角形数量
然后呢
我的computer shader里面就会把所有的instance的
所有的乘客
所有的cluster
所有的三角形全部跑一遍
最后呢我会输出一个最后可见的所有三角形的
一个超级大的index buffer
那他怎么办呢
他一上来会先分配一个大概八兆的这样的一个
伊森的buffer的这样的一个一个一个一个空间
然后呢你们所有的这个walking street
就是你们去便利所有的这个instance啊
所有的这个这个class唱歌啊
所有cluster所有船口
你们只要这个船口最后可降了
我就把你这个instance part
这个这个这个TRIGLE的信息index buffer p写进去
然后呢依次的往后去ding这个东西
为什么可以做呢
其实是因为就现在的这个GPU的话
它实际上能支持
就是说在这个computer shader里面
我可以并行的处理很多的工作
但是呢我能保证它的血的运算
具有一定的原子性对吧
但是这个你要做的不好的话
他互相就会你等我
我等你
但如果你写的他这个几乎是比较那个稳
就是比较工作量比较均匀的话
他们写的话真的是能够非常高效率的
往那个最终那个buffer里面去写写写写写
当然这里面有个细节
就是说因为我的所有的这个instance的便利
所有的cluster的便利
实际上都是并行的
所以那个instrument buffer那个英特尔谁先写谁后写
其实可能是乱序的
这种外序呢本身没有什么太大问题
但是如果这些几何的密度特别特别的高
那么你会出现什么情况呢
就是比如说啊啊在第一针的时候
诶
我同样是这些可见的物体
我的渲染顺序可能是啊instant1
然后呢instant5
instant8对吧
但是呢我到第二针的时候
我可能变成了insert5INCENT8int一
那么这个渲染呢
因为z buffer它本身的精度啊
它还是有限的
可能会产生一个z fighting
所以呢作者在他的那个presentation的后期会讲到
就是说诶因为硬件厂商提供了叫multiple multi director
扩对吧
它可以锁死这个inn的绘制的顺序
那么a cluster绘制的顺序
因此CROSSC绘制的顺序
这样的话呢它能避免这种the fighting的现象出现
但这个是一个非常小的这样的一个hack trick
不过同学们在做这个render的时候
其实特别注意一件事情
就是说我们希望就是在针与针之间的话
我们一些渲染它的顺序最好是deterministic的
否则的话呢当这个几何的密度特别高
而且贴的非常近的时候
比如说啊我举个例子大家就知道了
比如说啊我们在墙上再加一层贴花的几何对吧
他两个几何之间就非常的近
那么当你的这个相机离得稍微有点远的时候
那个z buffer的精度就不够了
那么你是先画那个贴画
就是那个想细节几何再画墙面
还是先画墙面再画细节几何呢
那个Z会产生fighting的
所以他两个的顺序确实要保证起来
否则的话你画出来的东西它就是不对的
但这里面的这是一个非常细节的一个东西
但是大家如果在做真正做游戏的时候
大家需要注意这些细节
所以呢这一步核心的就是说
我把所有的物体全部变了一遍
把它里面所有的COSER全部变了一遍
然后我把所有可见的传统customer
可见传口全变
我把所有的在这一帧相机下的可见的传统
build成了一个超级大的一个index buffer
我111个pass把它渲染完
诶
这个是不是就实现了
我们在之前GPU driven里面讲的那句话叫做哎
我们从JOEPRIVITI变成了JING对吧
而且这个calling是非常彻底和充分的
哎这就是这个刺客信条大革命
它最核心的一个一个渲染上的一个想法
这个想法说实话
在那个时候我们刚刚看到的时候
确实是惊为天人
就是觉得哇塞这个老哥还是挺猛的
居然敢这么搞
甚至是会觉得哇这个这个会不会
这个导致这个CPU上的运算过过于负载
但是你后来发现就是说确实这样做
对于那种非常细密的这种高精度几何的话
确实是效率最高的一种做法
而且呢这个也毫无疑问就是逐渐成为了
我们下一代这个rendering pipeline的一个
可以说是个标准解法之一吧
OK那么这里面其实有很多的细节了
比如说像baha calling作者提出了一个想法
就是说哎我可以在一个cube上面去CODEC
就是说我有128个面
对不对
那你每个面对于我一个cube的六个面来讲
你到底是可见和不可见好
那我有了这个cube之后呢
当我一个相机的视角过来之后
其实我就可以知道说
因为你这三个面对于我可见
所以你那个三角形的话
假设这三个面中只要有一个人的B特
是是是是亮的话
那这个东西我就是亮的
因为你总共就是64个三角形嘛
所以说我六个6×64个
这个这个vector就能表达我三角形的这个可见性
这一点其实非常的重要
因为其实back is calling的话呢
用这个方法速速度是很快的
当然了
就是说其实在NANA里面的话
好像没有用到这个技术
但这个技术我觉得是一个非常好的一个trick
所以其实呢这个就是我们这个最原始的就是
cost based mesh rendering的一个思想
其实非常的简单对吧
大家想想哎
理解了就不难了
但这里面又引入了另外一个细节
就是说哎这么多的cluster
我如果只是用wow fashion对吧
那我实际上那么多的几何层层叠叠的话
那后面那些几何画了不是全都浪费嘛
对不对
而且你虽然说我们说一个周末对吧
一个JING就可以把所有的现在可见的这个
传染狗的可见
但是其实你背后藏着很多实际上是被遮挡掉的
这些cluster我也绘制了
这一点
其实对于rendering来讲的话是非常重要的
为什么呢
因为其实大家知道
就是说如果没有做clusion culling
基本上所有现在游戏它的性能都差得一塌糊涂
真的就是啊当大家做游戏的时候
经常会遇到一个性能的bug
就是如果库存卡里没做
对对吧
那你会发现同样一个场景
直接就帧率下降个级别是很正常的
所以说其实接下来一个很重要的一件事情
就是说唉对于那种彼此遮挡的这些几何的话
虽然你都在我的相机的视野内对吧
虽然你所有的三角形面都嘲笑我
我能不能把你这个cluster整个给干掉
这其实是这个就是说啊
对于这种class based machinering的话
很重要的一个议题
同样的就是对这么细密的几何
那我就做你的shadow map的时候
我的天呐对吧
shadow map大家理解吗
就是说哎他要从光的角度再去渲染一帧
那它的复杂度呢很多时候不是由材质决定的
因为那个时候材质不重要
对不对
哎几何是直接决定了我渲染一个SHUTMAP的成本
那我怎么样在渲染它这个这么复杂场景的
shadow的时候
尽可能变得廉价
所以这也是就是说a cluster based rendering
很核心的一个技术点
就是ACLUSION怎么去calling
这一点的话
其实一直到我们本节课要讲的重点
拿net技术的时候
这也是一个非常核心的一个技术好
那作者怎么做呢
哎其实在大革命那个时代
他其实有一个非常聪明的一个想法
就是说我当前这个物体
我要去算他的这个这个这个东西可不可信
怎么办
我呢把上一帧他的depth
重新投影到我当前的相机位置啊
重新算一遍
因为大家知道在那个depth buffer里面
其实我们知道一个深度
其实我们还知道它的XY
就是实际上我们就知道了
在这个物世界坐标系里面
我们形成了一个怎么说呢
这个图很难表达出来
但是其实是一个像一个模样的
就每个模带深度对吧
这样的一个个的pixel呢
当我把它当我的相机位置换掉之后呢
这每个pixel其实可以重新
投影到我的新的相机位的
那么假设这个世界你的相机移动不要
那么就是跳它是一个光滑的移动
第二件事情呢
场景里大部分物体都是静止的话
那大家有没有发现
实际上这个ACCA的话呢
实际上是可以重用的
这是他一个很核心的一个观察
另外一个这个DEBUFFER可以重用
上一段代码可以重用
另外一个的话呢
作者呢他还想了一个trick
就是说我写了一个HEISTIC启发性的算法
就是因为我的场景里面有上万个
甚至是更多的这些物体
因此对象对不对
我有一套启发式算法
就告诉我说哪些物体就是很大
而且它离我相机很近对吧
我就把它作为优先的酷睿
我先找到300个
就是最有这个可能性的这些aqua
我先把它z buffer就是在我渲染出来
这样形成我的指导
然后呢桶把它呢就是当sample的
到我的512×256
然后呢我们再把上一帧的z buffer诶
把它REPROJECTION出来
那上一轮这样的话呢
因为你只选了300多个那个物体啊
实际上你会是那个Z8手上面有很多洞的
对不对
诶他把上一段东西representation过来呢
把这个洞填一填
对不对
然后这个时候我就用这个z buffer
我build一个HZHZ
大家还记得吗
就是说我的z buffer1层层的往上密铺
但是这个mp是很特别的
就是说我选择那个他的是应该是最近的那个Z
也是最小的那个Z
也就意味着说你跟我的hey test
如果过了就说明你肯定是没有被遮挡
如果没有过的话
你可能被遮挡对吧
它其实是一个啊保守5G诶
那我就可以去做这个GPU上的直接卡里面
因为我每个COSER不都是有绑定吗
对不对
或者我每个唱歌其实也有帮你
对每个音色也有帮你
实际上我很早就可以快速的判断出来
音色到底可不可见
如果伊森森的可见
那我的这个唱K是不可见
唱歌是不可见之后
那如果可见
我在问我的classroom能不能可见
这个想象想象起来其实是有点抽象的
但是大家去理解它的时候
就知道就是他有个很巧妙的想法
其实他想法分成两派
第一趴呢就是说我选就是我有一套启发式算法
选取三个最有可能去遮挡住别人的ACCORDA
把它先渲染出来
然后呢
我把上一帧的z buffer那个重新的REPROJECT一下
然后呢我就形成hey
这样我在GPU上能快速的做他的哭声
但这个方法会有什么问题呢
哎作者自己也讲了
我相信聪明的同学们可能很快就发现了
就是说如果上一帧Z里面的有些物体
它在这其实它是高速移动的物体对吧
那你在这一帧是不是就会产生问题啊对吧
那么这个问题确实是存在
但是据作者自己讲啊
说哎呀我这个虽然是in theory
理论上会有artifact
但是呢他说这个结果基本可以接受
但是呢我个人是觉得嗯
反正你游戏已经发布了对吧
我就相信你了
那么当然到后面的话呢
其实大家也提出了一个诶更有意思的方法
叫two face accursion calling对吧
这个呢其实是啊
当时和他们一起做研发的另外一个老哥
那个老哥他以前是个独立的公司
但是呢因为他后来被育碧收购了
他们两个两个团队会经常在一起协作哈
这个老哥的话呢
他提出的就是说两次的accushion calling对吧
那怎么去做呢
他首先的话呢把所有的物体对吧
用上一帧的这个Z去给它这个测试一遍
那这样的话呢
就是说我对于所有的
就是说那个通过上一帧的Z测试的物体呢
我把它快速的画一遍
其实那个时候已经就相当于
比如说我有1万个物体啊
我用上一帧再测试一下
我可能通过了
只有比如说啊100个
很多时候这个这个通过率其实是很低的
大家想这个真实的游戏场景里面去
通过率非常低
大家想象一下
就是说在一个复杂的巴黎的整个场景里面
你你站在一个街道里面
其实你满眼看到的也就是几十个建筑
但整个巴黎城可能有很大很大的
这个上万的建筑
对不对
所以呢唉我先用上一代Z
我去测试一下这个哪些物体可能可见好
我把这些所有可能可见的物体呢
我去按照当前的这个相机啊
就在当前的相机下
我跑一下干嘛呢
我形成我这一帧的新的Z
那但是呢你上一周通过的物体呢
他的那个Z可能会产生很多的动
这个大家要知道第二个呢
他对这个Z的这个表达很可能是错误的
那怎么办呢
哎他这个时候用这个生成的Z啊
把所有钢材
你认为不可见的物体也快速的测试一遍
注意啊
这个时候是用当前针下去测试的
他跟刚才那个用上一帧
那个强行的那个投影过来是不一样的
它是用当前的相机
用当前可能可见的物体的Z全部画了一遍
然后呢
这个时候用这个形成的新的
这个这个depth的话
去测刚才被过滤掉了所有的物体诶
这个时候他就会发现一些新的物体又可见了
哎这个这个方法其实是非常巧妙的
实际上你可以认为就是说他用上一帧的那个Z
做了一次提前过滤
但是这个过滤呢大家不用担心
它是一个保守过滤
也就是说你所有被过滤掉的物体在后面
当我在这个depth空间又填了一些东西之后
再被测一遍
这样的话呢
其实我就可以省掉大量物体的可见性的测试
这个讲起来有点抽象
但这个方法的话呢
实际上是啊我们在做现代渲染的时候
很多时候大家会用的方法
这个方法的好处就是说啊它是准确的
就比如说在我的近处
有一辆马车高速通过的时候
你不用担心说这个Z是有错误的对吧
你大不了就是少a rude的几个物体
你在你在你后面的测试中一定能把它画出来
诶这个其实是啊
当时呃另外一个作者提出来对这个方法来改进
同学们需要花点时间去理解这个算法
那么但是呢就跟大家讲一下
就是对于这种所有的cluster base这种rendering的话
ACCUTION是一个非常复杂
但是呢又是非常重要的一个计算
它的基本思想就是什么呢
我尽可能快速的低成本的基于当前的相机
相机位置构建一个depth buffer
这个DEBUFFER呢我一旦有了之后
哎我就基于他beautiful beautiful high c
你可以认为就是我形成了一层层的幕布
当我拿到任何一个物体啊
任何一个cluster呀
无论你是用那个就是你是用什么东西表达了
你最后肯定有个绑定对吧
我用那个bounding和那HZ
能够快速的在GPU里面进行测试
这样的话
我就能迅速的把那些大量看不见的东西给踢掉
所以呢这个Z的那个挡板其实非常的重要
所以其实你可以发现他所有的这些算法
都是用尽可能低的成本
形成那个你想需要的挡板O所以这个地方的话
大家如果有兴趣真的去实现这个算法的话
我会建议大家两个算法都去实现一下
比较一下好
那么其实呢对于这个two faces的OQUENT
COLIN的话呢
它的效果还是非常好的
就是这个老哥
他自己这是一个非游戏的一个案例
他就做了一个在这个行星边界
漂漂漂漂浮的一片
那个叫做那个啊
我们叫做云小行星带
这里面有大概是啊
我记得是25万个这个小行星
或者是那个陨石
他这个呢这个他这个案例给的非常挑战
就是说陨石也是随时随地在动的
嘿他这个时候能够用这一套two pass的这个
accution coming in的算法的话
能够实现一个非常好的一个效果
所以这也是呢
我觉得这个算法它其实在那个时代吧
已经被提出且被很有力的验证过了
因为真实的游戏场景的话
我们动的东西的话呢应该到不了25万个
但是的话呢我的场景里的物体数量
可能还真的到这个数量
所以的话呢
这也是就是说LUCI算法的一个很大的优化
那同时呢在大革命时代的话
就是那个那个算法中的话呢
有一个很重要的技术是什么呢
就是shadow
因为shadow这件事情其实非常的难
就是说刚才我这样
我刚才讲的就是shadow
当我们如果大家对真实的写过一个游戏引擎啊
特别是你真的生成一个游戏级的场景的时候
你会发现就是casket shadow generation
在整个渲染pine中的话会占据非常显著的时间
它可能占据占据你前绘制时间呢
比如说到1/10到1/5都不止
想想看这是很大的一个成本啊
那么而且他的很可怕的一件事情是什么呢
它只和你的几何复杂度有关对吧
也就是你材质上做任何简化
它不受影响
而且呢我的shadow caster它的几何的进步
实际上要和我的这个camera space
看过去的精度是一致的
否则的话
你假设用一个低精度的几何去cast the shadow
你投到那个高精度的几何上的话呢
那两个的他的这个depth信息是不能匹配的
你会产生很多很脏的东西对吧
这一点也会让他这个过程变得非常的expensive
其实我们后面讲到nine的时候
shadow也会重点的去讲一下他的挑战
其实也就是在这个地方
那这个作者怎么去做呢
他其实思想跟刚才我们讲的cushion
calling的想法是一样的
就是说我要想方设法的在我渲染下的map的时候
尽可能少的渲染物体
而不要渲染太多的物体
那怎么办
他呢
首先一个就是说他把上一帧的shadow map
里面的那个depth buffer重新投影成我们这一帧
但是它精度采样的非常低
只有6464个pixel对吧
然后呢
我们把这一帧的这个这个就是说这个shadow的话
我会用它去快速的去进行一次卡里
把很多物体就用上一帧的那个depth
把它给裁掉了
你看这个老哥是不是很粗暴对吧
但这件事情其实非常的重要
因为否则的话你想想看
我要把整个巴黎城
在光的方向再给你绘制一遍啊
大家想想这是casket shadow
大家记得他的最后一层
可能是方圆几平方公里的物体啊
大家想想看这个是不是很要命的一件事情
所以呢这个时候我们要尽可能用这个
就是z buffer这个depth buffer
把它很多东西能挡掉
就尽可能挡掉
这样的话就是节约我的时间
那么这一点够不够确实不够
这里面我还想提一下
就是他在那个大革命这一组里面
提了一个很有意思的一个想法
就是说哎当我相机去平视
我在我的camera space生成一个depth buffer的时候
我对它进行采样
我把他的每1616个spring tel的话
我其实可以拿到一个他的
就是说最近的这样的一个一个一个depths对吧
我可以生成一个cube
那这个时候呢
其实我就可以知道说对于每一个物体的话
你对于我这个就是这个这个其实它不是个cube
是一个四棱柱的这个东西
你到底跟我有没有焦点诶
为什么这件事要这么做呢
其实你会发现啊
就这个地方我要讲一个细节
就是说之所以他这个方法
可以用一个很大的假设
就是说在这个游戏中的话
很多时候我们的建筑物是平的放在这
而人呢很多时候是走在街道上面
所以我的人一眼看过去的话
如果前面有一个比较近的物体挡住我的话
那这个近的物体啊
他大概率不会受到后面那个shadow的影响
为什么呢
因为他shadow形成那个VOLUO
和我的这个camera形成的涡轮
它两个之间是没有交集
所以在数学上你可以知道
就说那些shadow caster
实际上并不能有效的在我当前的这个相机位
投影到我的shadow诶
这个加上讲起来也有点抽象了
但实际上这个算法
我个人觉得对于这种向城市集的场景
渲染的时候
它能够帮助你非常高效的剔除掉很多的物体
那这样的话就像刚才我讲的
就是如果我要渲染一个casket对吧
我站在一个街道的中间
这个街道在拐角
其实我前面的几栋房子
它所形成的这样的一个一个一个切割面的话
它可以把大部分的后面的这个shadow caster
全部给过滤掉
那这样的话我的shadow才会比较高效
那大家看一下这个场景
对不对
大家回想一下
在游戏里面
是不是很多时候我们是站在这个视角
所以你前面几个房子它所形成的depth
然后呢
在空间上会有一个无线投影的
这样的一个
一个
一个一个就形成这样的一个
就是一个一个四棱锥的一个区域
那么我刚过来的时候
其实很多的就是instance的话
它的投影实际上是不可能出现在我的可见性的
这些追里面的那这些物体
当我去渲染shadow map的时候
我是不是可以完全跳掉
比如说我在这个里面的话
那栋房子就是那个远处接的那头
那个房子背后的整个巴黎城
其实在算shadow的时候
我也不需要投影
当然了
如果你这个东西特别特别的高对吧
我的算法也能告诉我说
诶不好意思
他还是会跟你有交集
但是呢能够达到那种高度的物体的话
在整个场景里应该没有几个
所以说那个这也是
我觉得
就是说他们在这个点上做了一个很深的优化
其实这里为什么要讲的这么细呢
我在想就是同学们如果想去理解NT
他很多技术的设计对吧
包括他们和我们提出了非常那个复杂的
叫virtual map对吧
其实都是在解决
就是说这个在这个camera space
在光的space如何高效的去渲染
能够把这么复杂的几何能够快速的做裁剪
只画我最有必要的一些东西
而且用我想必要的精度来绘制
这也是下一代的这个rendering pipeline
必须要思考和理解的东西
所以我个人认为就是说ACCUTION的话
是这个下一代渲染pipeline
非常核心的一个算法模块
这个地方如果做不好的话
那就算你把几何做的再高效
它实际上也是很难渲染的
非常好的对吧好了
我这句话是不是立了个flag
没关系
反正是我个人一家之言
大家可以不理我好
Ok
那这其实呢我今天讲的这个大革命的这个算法
实际上是啊
我们所有的这个cost base的这个geometry
rendering的一个老鼻祖吧
鼻祖之一
至少我至少我找的是最早的一篇文章了
那么好
另外一个呢跟NANA的很相关的一个工作是什么呢
叫做a visibility buffer
大家还记得我们前面讲rendering的时候
哎
最早的讲folder rendering对吧
那个然后呢后面讲的er rendering
大家different shading
大家都觉得大名鼎鼎
对不对
那么visibility buffer呢
实际上是一种现在越来越
这个就是那个引起大家关注的一个新的渲染
PAPI这件东西为什么这么重要呢
给大家解释一下
首先的话呢大家回顾一下
在我们前面课程中讲到低分的设定里面
讲到G8分
它实际上在解决什么问题呢
就是说哎我们一个场景放的是
如果我们用最简单的古老的这个shading对吧
那么我们叫forward rendering
那其实很多的几何是彼此被遮挡的
但是呢我在forward shading的时候呢
唉我的这些像素他都要进行这个什么呢
都要进行一次完整的texture采样啊
什么的采样全部做一遍
然后呢还做一次光啊
就变得非常的复杂
所以大家就发现
这里面其实是有很多的计算的浪费
其实另外一点也是我们的defending
最著名的一个点
就是说诶我假设有很多屏幕
screen space动态的光源对吧
那我每个光源所有影响到的几颗
我得再给它绘制一遍
还得叠加上去
这个过程变得非常的复杂
那differ shing说
哎我来解决这个问题
他把渲染分成了两步
第一步呢把所有可见的几何
他的诺他的那个法向啊
他的这个这个这个这个texture呀
他的diffuse啊
那个sparkler roughix啊
包括TG的这些数据
全部打到了一个screen with buffer里面
但注意这个buffer里面的话呢
它只会指你可见的这个pixel
然后呢我这时候根据你的光
我去shading这些pixel对吧
那这个的话就避免了很多不必要的pixel CD
这就是而且呢刚才如果你有很多动态光源的话
它可以在上面无限的去叠加对吧
如果你是talist rendering的话
你可以在每个屏幕的这个小的tale里面缩
我会受到比如说两个光源的影响
三光源的影响
我可以实现
这个就是最近很火的一个叫什么
thousand lies对吧
上千个光源在那里动来动去也没有什么问题
那这就是differ shading
之所以before the rending大家觉得比较好的地方
但是呢differ shading呢
它其实这个pine大概是这个样子
但是它会产生一个比较大的问题是什么呢
它在中间过程中啊
就是它会产生很多的
就是跟屏幕的分辨率一样的中间数据
比如说你要存normal
你要存阿B
你要存roughness对吧
就是形成了一个叫G8er
g buffer本身是很肥的
很大的
我们叫做feat g8er
那么这个发七八分呢
就是每个pixel我要存这个多少
可能是将近几十个
甚至是接近100个这种BT的数据
那其实大家知道就是在显卡中的话
我们的cash miss是很重要的嘛
那如果你的buffer过大过肥
比如说我们是4K4K屏的话对吧
那么多的像素
然后每个像素我要存这么多数据的话
那这个buffer光写一下
光去fetching一下
它就很废
所以呢这其实是这个differ shading的话
它在现代的绘制中
有的时候大家很诟病的东西
特别是大家如果做那个就是手游的时候
会经常讨论的一个问题
就是说因为积分确定用了G8分对吧
他的那个FB是非常厉害的
所以呢我们不能够直接上different shading
我们要用td base方法
再加上1hack
能hack出来一个类似different shading的方法
这其实也是这个原因导致的
就是因为手机上的那个就memory的那个带宽
是很紧张很紧张的好
那different shading的话呢
其实他真正最吃亏的地方在哪里呢
是在类似这样的一个场景
大家看到这个场景里面
它有很多很多的三角形
这个三角形有个特点是什么呢
就是说你在屏幕上找一个点射过去
因为这些植物的叶子它会层层叠叠
层层叠叠在一起
因为呢我没有办法保证
这些植物的叶子
是一定是从优先从靠近我的相机开始绘制对吧
如果他优先从我的靠近相机绘制的话
那其他的pixel都会被那个就是说哎
early z把它干掉
所以下面的那些挡在下面的那些叶子会看不见
那我不会产生性能的问题
但实际的绘制渲染的话呢
我并不知道我的这些几何提交到显卡中的顺序
对不对
就不受我控制
那好了呀
那就可能会出现
就是说对于屏幕上一个像素
我可能会绘制十几次
哎
这个设计是什么概念呢
就是对每一次这个pixel的话
我都要去把他的texture sample出来
把他的什么abele roughness normal
包括把它转成local space对吧
然后呢这个而且呢还要把它写到哪呢
这这一大堆这个texture sample运算本身就很废了
对不对
大家还记得我们前面讲过
每次take some something是什么呢
是一次TRAINOR差值
就是说首先要做个呃
你要找到对应的map对吧
在mp上下两层mp之间的差值
每个mp内部是什么呢
是一个binary差值是1trainer差值
对不对
我要做若干次trainer差值
算出他的这个这个color呀
他的那个那个那个ABEL啊
RAGHNESS这些数值
同时呢哎我这些乱七八糟的数据算好了之后
将近100个BT的啊
将近100个beat的这个数据我要往哪跑呢
我还得写到那个G8份里面去
那个G8份每次打开来往里面写一下框
一创数据好
下一次在绘制的时候
那个周会来了
我再来一遍啪
那其实大家知道就是说也许AU计算
对于这个现在的这个GPU来讲还OK
但是呢你大量的这种texture sampling
再加上往基本方面读写这个啊
这个写这个数据实际上性能就会变得非常的慢
所以对于像foliage对吧
像你比如说看到很多植被的情况下
那你的这个这个这个偶尔做是非常严重的
这个时候传统的differ shading的方法
它就会产生巨大的问题
哎这个就是很有意思的一个点啊
那这个时候怎么办
就有猛男横空出世了
他说来我们提出一种新的方法
叫visibility buffer对吧
他这个自称是一个cash friendly的一个方法
去这个这个去优化这个differ shining
这个最早这篇paper是我们查到的是2013年
他的方法是什么样子的呢
唉其实非常的粗暴
真的这个超乎大家想象的粗暴
他说呢我在这个我第一张渲染几何的时候啊
我不要像different trading
我把你所有什么什么材质啊
这么normal啊
这些全部采样
我觉得太费了
你呢就把几何给我汇上去
对于每个pixel呢
我在你的这个buffer里面只存几件事
那个比如说你的primitive id对吧
你的incident id放在这
当然它有很多有很多细节的
比如说这篇文章是原作者
他说我把哪些东西是有alpha mask的
哪些没有阿sa mask的
我也把它区分开了
他其实就表示两种不同的材质
就是有的是带阿尔法master的材质
我要走单独的设置通道
如果其实其他这个类似于
我们后面真正的就是说啊
就是叫我们叫产品级的这个微visibility buffer
based rendering的话
你们用的这个mature id
但这里面就可以理解成就是一种mature id吧
然后呢
他把它packing成一个32个比特的UINT对吧
我就把它直接打到这个screen speed buffer里面去了
大家看到就是这样的一个
比如说我的这个球这样的一个简单的场景诶
我最后打出来的全是一堆
这个叫instant index啊
全国index啊
还有这个material index
Material id
诶
你就形成了这样一个色彩斑斓
毫无这个可读性的这么一个东西
好这个pass渲染完之后
哎我接下来要做的事情怎么样呢
我要做shading了
这个设定就非常粗暴了
他呢首先拿到这个这个这个这些insert id
拿到全国id之后
他干什么呢
诶我可以把这个船给的四个vertex全部拿到
对不对
然后呢我知道camera所有的参数
其实我可以把这三个三个传狗啊
三个顶点投影到屏幕的空间
然后呢因为这个点呢我也知道它的深度
而且我也知道他的那个就在屏幕空间的
XUV对吧
所以我也知道他在那个我可以反算出来
他在那个三角形中间的重心坐标
然后呢好那我把三个顶点的UV
我也知道我三个顶点text3朋友都能拿到对吧
那我去通过重心坐标插值
可以查出我这个像素点
它应该有的这个比如说那个ABEL才出来
texture应该是什么样子的
RAGH才出来
应该是什么样子的对吧
spec才出来应该是什么样子的
然后这样的话
我接下来就可以开始对它进行设定了
因为我知道光在哪里嘛
对不对
那其实这个地方大家觉得就是哎呀
我的天呐
这个太粗暴了
因为以前这些工作啊
全部都是由rust rizer和vertex shader
做掉的对吧
所以vertex shader把每个顶点的数据算好之后
哎
我在rust riser的时候
把这些数据插值到每个screech pixel
他老人家说你们都不要做了
你只要在屏幕上打出了所有的这个这个
几何的id信息
我自己手动的去取顶点的数据
对它进行插值
然后呢我再进行设定
这个听上去好像非常非常的费对吧
但事实上呢他的速度比大家想象的快
那为什么呢
因为其实很简单
就是where is buffer里面取每个顶点数据的时候
其实它的CCHHOENDS是很高的
他很多时候就在那一小块子和你去取
那么第二点呢
就是因为你可以发现屏幕上
你看到一小块几何对吧
它实际上很多时候都是同一个三角形
所以说你是反复的取那个三个顶点的数据
那这样意味着什么
它的KASHMISS率是很低的
但我在前面跟大家讲过
对性能影响最大的是什么
是CASHMISS
对不对
所以的话呢但这一点它带来的好处是什么呢
就是说对于屏幕上
无论你多少层overdraw的这个节目水
你在前面真正付出的代价
就是打赢这个花里胡哨的ID
但那个计算量是极低极低的
等你把这个ID打印完之后
其实我在这个shading pass的时候呢
我绘制的永远是你屏幕上有多少个像素
我做多少次采样
所以我几乎是没有over做的这个cost
唉这个其实就是with buffer一个很核心的想法
那么这里面的话呢
就是这是那个另外一篇paper里
他讲了这个整个的PAPI对吧
我的这个几何放在这
他这边为什么没有网格
就告诉你说这种情况下
我只要关注几个
你的材质是什么呢
我其实不太特别不是特别在意
然后呢我把你的这个就是PROPD传go的id
包括你的material id全部打印上去
然后呢在那个就是后面shading pass的时候
我会做一个geometry reconstruction对吧
我把你的这个三角形的信息全部拿到
然后呢
我超值出来
我这个像素点的所有所需要的这个shading information
然后需要ly lighting
那么这个维斯比巴尔这个方法呢
哎大家去理解它呢
实际上它是一个非常有意思的东西
就是说它可以和传统的低分的设定结合在一起
这一点其实非常的重要
就是说在NANA中的话
我们也利用了这个特性
因为比如说就是说在我们的渲染中
如果有些几何
我还是用了传统的different trading对吧
它几何的over作并不是很多
但是呢有一些几何他真的就是这个密度太大了
我们就需要用维CB的buffer的方法
那我怎么把两种完全不同的绘制的东西
混合到一起呢
哎他这里面就提出了一个解法
就是说我首先呢在这个with a bility buffer
这个pass的话
我还是输出了vivid buffer
诶
我我有一个叫G8分
这个pass这个或者叫material pass
我把根据你的这里面存储的这个instance id
传个id
我把你的这个你要的那些什么啊
bile啊
SPECER啊
那个roughness
这些数据全部还是打在这个FRAMEBUFFER
打到你的g buffer里面去
然后呢
你那些走传统管线的同学
是不是也去写了G8份呢对吧
反正我有我们的
我们有Z8分嘛
所以不用担心他们的数据会产生这种唉
不必要的这样的一个一个冲突
最后我一上光过就是lighting pass的话
我完全不care
你这个g buffer的数据是来自于这个via via via buffer
这个pass还是来自于传统的pass诶
我给你直接上光
整个场景就渲染出来了
其实这一套架构的话呢
在早期的就是visibility buffer based
render里面是挺常用的
比如说在有的游戏情里面
我去渲染这个植被
就是我们叫做foliage对吧
那种灌木丛啊
小树林啊
树林上那么多树叶啊
哎我用的就是visibility buffer的这个方法
因为大家可能想象不到
比如说我要绘制一个丛林
forest的这样这样的一个一个场景的时候
其实啊你对它进行这种啊
就像素卡里是很难看的
因为你说那棵树挡在前面
他到底是透明还是不透明的呢
你觉得嗯他可能是不透明的
但是那个树上树叶上有很多洞对吧
那后面一眼看过去
那几十棵树
其实都你并不知道哪棵树叶被挡住对吧
这个时候就很很很麻烦
那怎么办
像这种密密麻麻的这种复利计的
这种情况的话呢
我们一般会倾向于用VIVITY发布的方法
去节约这种overdraw的这种cast
但是呢当我画那个主角对吧
主角很帅
我们画主角
我们画那个一些近出的一些物体的时候
其实你没有必要用无zz buffer这么复杂的方法
你怎么办呢
哎你就可以用传统的different shading
然后呢最后在g buffer那边汇合
我最后给他来一个final的lighting
这个呢其实也是一个非常重要的pipeline
那这个呢也是我们去理解nmt rendering的话
一个很重要的基础对吧
所以我们今天在讲这一课的时候呢
我们不会就着那就讲
我们先把大家把这些基础知识全部建立好
所以呢这是一个就是vcb buffer
这个方法的一个很核心的一个思想
那么这个思想呢
其实他当然有很多的细节需要处理
其实其实你用wily buffer去做rendering
还有蛮多的细节需要处理
我这边只举一个简单的例子
就是说哎我们以前做texture的时候
我们要算他明白对吧
以前是在那个就是啊vertex shader里面做完之后
rus rise它就自动给你生成了DDXDDY
那么就是说当我们做texture sampling的时候
我调硬件的API的话
它自动会帮我选择正确的密码
但是当你只是把这个船狗的id
打印到那个像素的时候
我怎么知道他DDXDY呢
其实在那个就是说reb buffer render的时候
我还得做一部额外的处理
说哎我知道这个点在这对吧
我得根据我那个小三角形的三个顶点UV
我把它投影到screen space
这样的话其实我就可以算反算出来这个UV的话
就是这个点的这个这个pixel
他的那个UV的在screen space啊
注意啊
是不是在几几何空间
是在screen上的梯度到底怎么样
这样就能够告诉我说
我到底该采mini map的哪一层的运算
这里面的细节我就不展开了
但是的话呢大家注意
就是说
如果我们自己去写这个via visibility buffer based
rendering的话
那么就大家一定要注意这些细节
否则的话你生成的结果会有很多的artifact
就像这个图上给出来的说
诶你在这个凳子的拐角有看到很多的小白边
但实际上是因为它两边的密度不匹配
导致的这样的一个问题
所以呢其实这个visibility buffer rendering
他其实对于这种非常密集的这种
overdraw的这种情况
比如说几何特别的细碎很多小几何
而且彼此之间层峦叠嶂的这种状态的话
他是一个最好的解
其实原作者当时给了一个sample
就是对于一个有800万个三角形的这样的
一个场景的话
他会发现
就是说当你的屏幕的精度越来越大的时候
诶你走这个visibility buffer
它的性能就会遥遥领先于deer shing
但是这个他这个测试做的其实有点早了
距离现在已经有78年了
其实我很好奇啊
其实对于现代的显卡来讲的话
我猜这个差距不但没有变小
可能会变大
为什么呢
大家还记得我们在那个课程中讲过
就是说哎我们的就是那个显卡的算力
很多时候是这样上去的对吧
但是呢我们的memory的这个速度很多时候是这样的
他两个是不匹配的
就是对于visb buffer这个方法来讲的话
你的算力越强
它实际上它的优势就会越大
哎
这也是为什么在我们后面要讲到
NAS的绘制的时候
它就会直接采用了这个机制
就用vivisibility buffer的方法去shading
最后我渲染出来的这个NANA的这个几何
也是这个基础
所以呢这也是我们讲NNT非常重要的一个基础
那基本上讲到这儿呢
我们算是把这个就是NANA的两个前导的知识点
给大家讲清楚了
接下来呢就进入到我们今天的神坑了
就给大家讲讲NANA到底是怎么做的对吧
包括他自己提了一个非常大气的名字
叫virtual geometry
待会我跟他讲一下
为什么它叫virtual geometry